welcome to the presentation on level two
edition well I think we should get
started with some problems and hopefully
as we work through them you'll you'll
have an understanding of how to do these
types of problems see let me make sure
the pen tool is correct okay let's say I
had eleven plus four so at first you'd
say hey Sal you know eleven plus four
I've never you know I don't know how to
add two-digit numbers yet well there's a
couple ways we can think about this
first I'll show you how all you have to
know is how to add one digit numbers and
you could use something called carrying
to solve the whole problem and then
we'll actually try to visually represent
it to show you how you could actually do
this type of problem in your head as
well
so what you do with these types of
problems is you first look at this the
rightmost digit on the eleven we call
this the ones place right because this
one is 1 and we call this the tens place
and I know I'm going to confuse you a
lot but that's that's just so how
everything looks
that's so everything looks easier later
on ok so you look at this ones place you
say there's a 1 there you take that one
and you add it to the number right below
it so 1 plus 4 is 5 you need that right
all right you know that 1 plus 4 is
equal to 5 and that's all I did here I
just said this one plus this 4 is equal
to 5 now I go to this one this 1 plus
well there's nothing here other than a
plus sign and that's not a number so
this 1 plus nothing is 1 so we put a 1
here and we get 11 plus 4 is equal to 15
and just so you know that the system
actually works let's actually draw it
out in a couple of different ways just
to give you the intuition of 11 plus 4
so if I had let's say 11 balls let's see
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
that's 11 right 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
and I should do it like they do in
Sesame Street 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 I
actually messed up at 11 anyway
it's early I'm being a little ridiculous
okay so that's 11 and we're going to add
4 to it so 1 2 3 4 so now all we have to
do is count how many total circles or
balls we have now it's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 15 and I don't
recommend that you do this every time
you do a problem because it'll it'll
take you a long time but hey if you ever
get confused it's better to take a long
time than to get it wrong and let's
think about another way of representing
this because I think a different visual
approaches appeal in different ways to
different people let's draw a number
line I don't know if you've seen a
number line before but you're going to
see it now and a number line all I do is
I draw out all the numbers in order so
it's 0 1 2 3 or 5 6 I'm doing them small
so I know I can get to 15 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 18 and so on and it
and these arrows mean that the numbers
keep going in both directions and I know
this is a little early for you to learn
this but actually the numbers can
actually keep going to the left below
zero as well I'll leave you to think
about that but anyway so let's go back
to this problem so we have 11 so let me
circle 11 let me see where eleven is on
the number line 11 is here right this is
11 and we're adding 4 so when you add
that means we're going to go we're going
to we're going to increase 11 by 4 so
that when you increase we're going to go
up the number line right we're going to
go to the right on the number line
because the numbers are getting bigger
so we'd go 1 2 3 4 BAM we're at 15 once
again this takes a long time but if you
ever get confused or you forget what 1
plus 4 is although I don't think you
should
good then you could just do it this way
let's do some maybe harder problems now
let's do let's do 28 plus seven okay
eight plus seven I'll tell you frankly
even to this day I sometimes get
confused with eight plus seven so let's
if you if you know the answer then then
you already know how to do this problem
you could just write whatever the answer
is right here but let's let's draw it
out on a number line it's because I
think a little bit of just a more basic
addition practice isn't unwarranted at
this point so we could do out with the
number line again eight plus seven and
this time I'm not going to start at zero
I'll start it like five because you know
if you keep going you'll get to zero
eventually so let's say you get five six
seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
18 and so on it'll keep going all the
way to 100 and a thousand and a million
billion trillion so what are we doing we
started eight because we're saying eight
plus seven right we want to figure out
what eight plus seven is so we started
eight and we're going to add seven to it
let me change colors so you go one two
three four five six seven all that 15
shows up again so eight plus seven is
equal to 15 and over time as you do
practice I think you'll you'll memorize
these that eight plus seven is fifteen
or you know whatever 6 plus 7 is 13 or
any of these but um in the interim it
actually doesn't hurt to do this number
line because you're actually are
visualizing what's happening and you
could do it with the circles as well so
you know 8 plus 7 is 15 so this is this
is this is a new thing you're going to
learn right now you don't write the
whole 15 down here you write the 5
all right you write this 5 right here
and then that one you carry the 1 you
put it up there and I think in a future
present
and I'll explain why this works and
maybe you might even kind of have an
intuition because the one is in the tens
place and this is the tens place I don't
want to confuse you so you have that one
and now you add it to the two and you
get 35 right because 1 plus 2 is equal
to 3 right and so you're done 35 and you
might ask well does that make sense that
28 plus 7 is 35 and there's a couple of
ways I'd like to think about this well 8
plus 7 we know is 15 right and I don't
know how comfortable you are with higher
numbers but 18 plus 7 so let's look at
this pattern 8 plus 7 is equal to 15 18
plus 7 and honey you're probably thinks
out where you getting the 18 from but
stick my word for it 18 plus 7 is 25 28
plus 7 is equal to 35 which is the one
that we just did it's a check mark mark
and if you kept going you said 38 plus 7
that actually equals 45 so you might see
a little pattern here and then you can
just sit and think about this for a
little bit if you if you like maybe you
pause the video another way you can
think about this if you don't if you
still don't believe me is to say okay if
I have 28 if I add 1 I get 29 if I add 2
I get 30 if I add 3 I get 31 if I add 4
I get 32 if I add 5 I get 33 5 6
I get 34 and if I add 7 I get 35 again
right all I did is I kept saying oh if I
had one more I'll get on one a larger a
little bit a number a little bit larger
so let's do some more problems and I
think we'll do a couple more let's do a
little faster because I think you might
get what we're doing here now let's do a
hard one let's do 99 plus 9 so what's 9
plus 9 so if you if you don't know what
it is you could work it out either using
the number line or drawing the circles
and you know that's a fair way to do it
although you should eventually kind of
know it 9 plus 9 it turns out is 18 9
plus 9 is
equal to 18 so 9 plus 9 you put the 8
down here and you carry the 1 and now
you just say 1 plus 9 you don't 1 plus 9
is 1 plus 9 is equal to 10 and so
there's nowhere to carry that this one
so you write the whole thing down here
so 99 plus 9 is equal to 108 let's do
one more problem let's say 56 plus 7
well what's 6 plus 7 well 6 plus 7 is 13
right if you get confused draw out
everything again and then you get 1 plus
5 1 plus 5 is 6
63 and you might want to give yourself a
bunch of problems and and I think you're
all so now if you understand what we did
ready to try the level 2 addition
problems have fun